[Music]
we've just completed our July council
meeting and it was kind of meeting which
was a lot of small things but also
making progress for our district one of
the things we've been looking at for
some time is how to improve connections
between white Corvette and Pegasus it's
been a difficult one because carpet we
power Road which is an obvious route to
take is very important for noted a
really being right next door to car park
and to do as we round there would be
very difficult for a number of reasons
so what we are now looking at and have
now approve the funding for is a walkway
cycle way from territory Moana Drive to
wipe aqua beach so we have me to all the
consultation processes yet so it's not
finally decided but we've certainly set
aside the funding for that we have a
disability strategy it's to make sure
that as a council we're looking after
people with disabilities in building
consents and now rolling in our
footpaths and we are due to review this
and so we're going to be looking at over
the next few months and again we will be
looking for community important to that
and working with the 100 exs group who
are a permanent advisory group to the
council as well as the wider community
the council agreed to transfer the
assets we hold through our former rule
fire function to fire an emergency New
Zealand orpheens as it's often being
called I think the important thing is
first of all we need to acknowledge the
huge contribution to our community that
rule firefighters have made over the
years and included less courses our rule
far off certain Sheppard but just to
remind people that the function is still
there the rural firefighters are still
there still working for our community
and performing a very important role and
and all of our rural communities
[Music]